this is what it is me you don't you
don't get to [ __ ] come on your own
[ __ ] time like BC time [ __ ] that
start the [ __ ] show you're on so
isn't this the [ __ ] isn't is the
guess eat that's the guess see sorry
sorry
[ __ ] I mean welcome to the fighter in
the kid my fighter in the rap fighter in
the rap show fighter in the round I mean
still when I guest-hosted that time I
mean I don't know it's been a couple of
years writings were through the roof
yeah always go through the roof I mean
at this point Brendan it's almost like
you're you're maybe senior you're sort
of outgrowing this [ __ ] gotta get you
you've jumped like in the beginning
let's talk about it again you've you
[ __ ] sucked
you were bear like you were still punchy
you're a bear like good we go go go foot
coconut yeah man no you're like leaps
and bounds this guy's [ __ ] late
he's gotta hold me back in me he's it's
it's redundant he's losing his mind
losing his [ __ ] mind
losing his [ __ ] hair lose it Eve lose
is he losing teeth well noticed either
just cricket in yellow but it's
disturbing and he doesn't smoke no if
you got crooked and yellow teeth and you
don't smoke cigarettes how's this and
you're in show business Larina
[ __ ] Hollywood we're literally you
could go to a 7-eleven and get your
teeth clean correct people don't know
that about laziness and he's gonna walk
in here at some point in like I'm not
moving I could how many times they text
you guys on time I agree and I showed up
early I was on time
[ __ ] here he is our team is we
[ __ ] started this show the [ __ ]
shows two minutes were two minutes into
the show we started at 11:30 why are you
dressed like that
you know weightlifting what are you
[ __ ] lifting weights you a little
pretty little button is this is this
trainer who's literally 300 pounds out
of shape yeah you have a 300 pound out
of is the trainer the same guy your
dentist
cuz somebody was just saying that your
teeth are yellow don't I guess he's
always coming in hard be governing super
alright
yes you're up too many house hunting
shows how solid the shows late yo you my
Minj take the guest chair it's to fight
on your lap my back dude I have my back
hurts get in the [ __ ] me a little
button dick you just showed you like you
just do it on campaign there's no they
like we told you they're not points
that's your little button dick your
points down B why are you dressed like
this bro I don't never because I reign
did one thing rap I can guarantee you as
long as I live you will never see me in
gym clothes in a studio gym clothes
those are gym clothes trained dude it
was a straight-up gym club I have I did
two this morning I don't know about that
bro - what was your workout my workouts
at 8 a.m.
no what what I didn't see what time I'm
just saying that you're no longer I feel
like you're no longer punchy punchy I
needs man okay so don't listen the theme
of the show today is is Brian is Brendan
outgrowing you like it are you see
basically like are you like a duffel bag
you know when you go to the airport lot
you know when you travel like Mexican I
don't like this team at all but you know
when you travel like Mexico and you're
like you could just have one carry-on
yeah but if you if you if you can't get
go on Karen you're gonna have to check
everything your that check the bag
don't you [ __ ] dare we're talking
about in Mexico we're not talking about
a great Airport in Mexico we're not like
we then we got to go get you off the
[ __ ] bag like all right Brian okay
don't you ever I am not extra baggage to
say these deadweight they don't think at
first you were the guy yeah and you were
like doing this [ __ ] sad sack of
favor yeah okay and how many episodes
are we in here on the showings okay 500
and and now it's like care if you're
that bag in - no no you gonna turn me
into a bag I'm not a bad bad you know
and I want let's just I'm gonna jump
right into a few things last year I came
on the show early in the season like
around this time like February or March
yeah dominated alright and easy take
these dominated and I actually invented
the fighter and the kid guest of the
Year award I imagine I guess you kind of
did after you yeah and self-anointed
myself the guest of the year yeah three
years straight
yeah last year you had who are some of
your good guests from 2017
was it let me guess was it one of your
comedian friends all right all right but
I tell them on Twitter all of them
listen this is not like beef okay no
like I'm the best guest that comes on
this show the people know that and I
want to just say this right like this
rough right now though because you're
you're it's a fact it says it's bad I
want to say this doll I want to say this
though forget being the best guests on
the show yeah obviously we know that I
have the eye on Rappaport stereo pockets
at this point I want the people decide
if the I am rapport stereo podcast
myself stereo podcast the I am rapport
stereo pockets is actually better than
the fight or not get the ad stereo like
it there's an excellent out here that's
super annoying to me right well you got
this book what's your name
Jen chin you got [ __ ] chin doing the
sound y'all right so that ain't in
stereo that's flat again no I am rapport
stereo pop oh that's so annoying I get
the name the fighter in the Killa trade
name I am rapport stereo puck is great
no no what the people say Casterly Rock
ignores the iron that doesn't roll
I am Rappaport stereo podcast not the
fighter in the kid podcast like oh yeah
we know it sounds shitty well why Stu I
know though first of all I was just
called the fighter if you want the full
name it's the fighter and kids surround
sound Dolby XTS that vodka yes but a lot
of people come on here to promote stuff
right that is usually the other thing I
come on here for for for the honey not
for the money
correct it's true time's up last year
you guys tried the fluid times out
hashtag times off y-hat second times up
times up around no in terms of in terms
of like I'm not just gonna come on here
and be belittled by your guests
belittled by some of your Twitter faith
we know I was the best guest last but
Chris
is the iron Rapaport stereo podcast
that's so annoying the better it has it
surpassed the fighter in the keynote and
I'm saying are you asking that question
we have it that is even a question our
favor gonna disagree all your fans can
see your fans don't just listen to the
fighter and the kid trust me and I'm
saying that I'm training up like Frick
forget the guest of the year yeah like
if your show of the year the better
podcast like announcing it turns tonight
into a podcast competition right now
sort of kind of do we can open a poll if
you want did it's gonna be skewed by our
guests but we don't need to do that I'm
just saying I want your guests your fans
and I want to say this the first ever
podcast I ever did
yeah ever and you know you know what
let's say let's cut world podcast host
yeah when you're interviewing people
what would you say the most important
thing is if you're interviewing me
what's the most important thing is to
listen okay tell us now check this out
do you can you name the first podcast I
ever did the purse first podcast you
ever did this is why he's not a good
listener was probably the fighter and oh
no no it was is that now-defunct
Bryan Callen so right and you said and I
said I said if you could do a [ __ ]
podcast [ __ ] definitely doing it
really may be a trap right now and you
know what he said in the middle of the
podcast we're doing it and this is on
Saturday my hotel room and he goes like
this in the middle and nobody could see
it because I guess in the middle of my
answering question he goes why are you
not wearing pants right it doesn't make
any sense and now you're taking her
shirt off actually thought I was I had
to tweet back on is like that was the
very first podcast I did and after that
you allowed to do your I was like [ __ ]
if they're paying this guy a [ __ ]
nickel to [ __ ] it none of you is [ __ ]
his nonsense
lies and exaggerating the facts about
reading things that I got marina [ __ ]
my reader yeah any brains about life
anything kugels not reading like [ __ ]
like cliff notes aren't real oh how dare
you I mean you can now google the cliff
notes that's true you know what else my
daughter does home
I call the l9 I thought of doing this
yeah I don't know if your kids do this
and it made me mad I swear to god she
goes Alexa what's the square root if I
was like all right that's it that's what
kids get so terrible what kids need to
learn math these days well no it's true
what you want to do is learn how to get
to the conclusion because it teaches
your brain that a thing did the basic
stuff but but you got to think about it
like we're so removed from that like
statistic that no one used name that
last time anyone in here you know you're
bringing up a good point cuz can you do
basic division no no [ __ ] I know
right now if you gave me like a like a
six number basic division problem
struggle City like I'm probably you
would catch on for a while but I'd be
like [ __ ] holy is we don't do it you
know what they say is that something or
do you need the old smart was like you
get a lot of facts in your brain the new
smart doesn't need that anymore cuz you
can turn to it you know your middle in
Charlotte yeah you guys have young kids
so I my kids are a little older they
grew up on that [ __ ] they did that's it
how did you get your kids to because the
one thing I worry about is my kids they
can't waste over the I leg dude it once
you give it to them it's you know rack
for its drugs once they see it it's over
you know even my son at two he wants his
I baby plays with the the videos so the
big thing over the big owners of these
big tech companies from Tim Cook who
runs Apple they're all to know that we
summer together and they always ever
yeah we summer together together and
yeah in an area an exclusive area you
guys walk around in gym clothes we we
train together we eat and exercise so
when high functioning people realize
like a fighter or like an NFL player
train trains not what you did this
morning that's going to the gym or
working out I do Olympic weightlifting
dude that's the sport so if you want to
come down and watch the exclusion can
you do 50 pushups right now easily
easily don't dare but you can't you're
too big right 50 puts up straight I'll
do a man a clip now he's stupid strong
yeah you know he's to pay 100 hey bro
did you just say not a chance yes I've
seen your bird chest I could do I could
do 50 pushups right straight do legit
push-ups well show me my legit push-up
is we know what like you're [ __ ] like
you're like our kid I'll do I'll do 50
dude okay but Han I would love if he's
doing the push-ups a we could continue
our great conversation meet it was fun
rap is fun but wait I want to hear
first two minutes of the fighter in the
kid today are actually like you should
rewind it was [ __ ] literally like
that we're at the baggage claim what
we're like [ __ ] like the [ __ ] no man
momentum you how many jobs would you say
you have right now well last year all
last year I have less jobs now and and
and I'll always take a lot of jobs but
but last year I had a lot you know we're
gonna do like the white Samuel Jackson
do you say no to anything [ __ ] no my man
you're [ __ ] hosting the Grammys in
purple crushed-velvet correct jackets
and you're talking about do you say no
to anything I turned on the [ __ ]
Grammys and I was like that guy no not
my guy with a purple crushed jacket
sitting there talking about fashion but
then I said to myself number one number
one this makes total sense because it's
like a straight tough guy you are about
as fashion-forward like you I'm
surprised you're not wearing some like
it's annoying isn't it I mean today's
this is normal but like jeans and [ __ ]
like this is right normally I crush you
will let you do and I've seen this
[ __ ] terrible those Gucci boots with
the Bison yes I last time ozoni were
that good anyone talking to me like the
gucci boots with the buckle or dope
right oh no I was wearing my Saint
Laurent boots cuz you and I I know I
know and they're like they're probably
like I think they're $1,500 for unwrap
you you have more jobs than I do
yeah wait more jobs than I do ROC Howard
that you got to do it nowadays not only
do you got to do it you can do it you
know like when you first started I was
an actor you're an actor the the with
the social media and the the old world
and the podcasting and the videoing and
all the book writing and book audio book
writing and all that [ __ ] it's not like
you necessarily have to but why wouldn't
you wouldn't you and and the days of a
traditional movie star there's there's a
handful of them DiCaprio he's the only
ya Triple A List actor who's never done
a talk show yep that'll never happen to
me on a talk show
never he doesn't do any loser and he's
on that senior Rando [ __ ] but but it's
not smart it's like you he can do that
anything
but like everyone else you days are over
it's over
the movie business is all [ __ ] up the
TV business you if you're doing a TV
show you're gonna put yourself out there
so as far as you know taking a job
having a job wanting a job like for me
the podcasting and the videos and the
sports stuff it's it's like I love it so
[ __ ] much it's so much fun um and
when you're not on a set either doing
something good or a piece of [ __ ] and
we've done them all yeah let's have fun
though
by the way I'd always fun really [ __ ]
movies I've done and things I had so
much higher going on right boys
yeah and not by the way my will I like
the movie we did this but Mike it didn't
really didn't do that well but you how
much fun they think it's funny yeah we
had a blast a wrap don't you think in
this day and age and be - don't you
think like the days of just doing one
movie and then you ride off that for a
friend just like that stay relevant I
can paint what I'm saying even as a
personality whatever you want to call
yourself an actor comedian you have to
stay relevant and yeah and you're the
kids attention span these days a lot of
time party this know like he'd like and
he's that's all he wants to do and God
bless him he's doing his thing but buzz
it venom I like talking [ __ ] I like
talking sports I didn't have to come do
this you [ __ ] bend me wrap can you do
it please come down
please come down all the way up all the
way up dope all the way up sir see how
your elbows alright go all the way up I
didn't have to come here and do this
podcast is the point you say but I'm
doing it because I want to and also it's
like we're friends the ratings and you
need the rating but the pressure and the
guilty sell books but also like it's
like you said be can I please come on so
many books to sell they're not going off
the shelf so I was like alright come on
the show no but Brendon it's like you
know at a certain point like why why
don't count B there's no count those
don't think it is the last I know we get
such a [ __ ] those aren't real push
ups start again start again restart
start again
tighten those worries just bobbing your
head like they got weaker machine
[ __ ] apple bobbing look at them
that's
a little he said [ __ ] like you're like a
little going it if those doesn't count
why am i doing it take out of our face
bro my man how will you know how old are
you Reb 47 to him coming 48 more how old
you Oh 34 you know what happens I knew
what I if I know if I knew what I knew
if I knew what I knew yeah get it out
for me Brian if I yeah if I knew what I
knew no no if he knew what he knows now
at 34 I heard that Steve he'd be
shooting he doing a super ball rap Brian
take a hike I thought it was I thought
it was I thought it was a really good
Super Bowl I mean I was so [ __ ] beat
down by the Saints losing to Minnesota
and then so beat down by the Jaguars
losing to New England I can't ever root
for the Patriots ever ever why I just
says you from New York I'm a Giants fan
we don't root for the Patriots we [ __ ]
the page whoa do you like to do you
respect Tom Brady Morris of course you
can't not respect him you can't ever
stand you guys team sucks so bad we had
a terrible season but but but of course
you can't not reason we have to like
them just like you know what like the
Celtics were kicking ass with Larry
burna didn't like them just like I can't
stand LeBron Jamie comes with the
[ __ ] territory that makes sense
they're sick I respect the [ __ ] out of
him like the Patriot Way and all that
stuff but I'm glad Philly won but like
as a New York fan you can't really [ __ ]
with the Philadelphia Eagles but I love
the city of Philadelphia me too love
Philly so I was rockin with Philly that
you know what I was happened I wish
Carson Wentz would have won the Super
Bowl can you imagine how salty is like
that was his squad and now they're
talking about like yo homeboy Nick Foles
just just took your [ __ ] do you think
because hearts and wets was gonna be MVP
I know he's he won MVP second expose was
the his holes it's easier please use the
bag he's the back he was gonna put a
Super Bowl MVP amazing quote-unquote
beat Tom Brady and he was gonna retire
last year he's like sort of up - I'll
try
for Andy Reid so he's the backup
Rocksmith and then filly got depth in
and just killed it to be a veteran he's
been playing a long time in the NFL
he's not a long time you sort of never
reached you've never been the guy he
never found his mojo and now he's now
does he get traded to another team now
no no no during a problem because he's
been starting no Carson Wentz was
literally gonna win MVP like he's a
better quarter because it better
quarterback he's up be scarred Oh winces
so then so they have a problem it
basically looks a good prob might keep
him as a backup he's not gonna want this
out because he's you know I'm super on
VP I'm not [ __ ] bad right I'm saying
he doesn't follow sports good so check
this out like if you got injured and I
started hosting this show and the show
would be like you know like when I
hosted at that time the highest rated
not kill and then you come back and like
we're like well do we want to drop to
the bottom and I don't I don't like that
you're abusing this as a put your hand
like that I mean I got a more just warm
because I react so quickly but but
here's what here's what would you do
yeah I don't honestly I don't know what
girl Carson Wentz I'd go to curse once
but you know what I'm a Giants fan I got
my own [ __ ] problems
I've rooted for the few guys need Nick
Foles that would be sick but but Eli's
not going anywhere I don't think yet I
like to UI man yeah me too he's not I
don't think he's gonna leave me see the
commercial you know I did that I think
what a superball hilarious came in Odell
dancing hilarious but check this out did
you see after the Super Bowl because I
want to pose this question two things
happen number one while Rob Gronkowski
you know he is yeah it's the fighter in
the kid do you know I know the tight end
for the [ __ ] you know guy Pat says okay
and I'll tell you something else a
really bother me my wife as after he
spiked the ball my wife cuz that's a man
and I went what yeah she said that yeah
do you like you know arouse you I got me
it turned me on but then I had this red
looking weights this morning that's
right that's enough cuz I'm gonna be as
big as God yeah so during the Super Bowl
while Gronkowski one of the most beloved
figures in all of Boston sports history
captain of Bros yeah he's up there he's
got to be top five with like Larry Bird
[ __ ] you know you think in terms of
I'm not saying he's I'm singing up he'll
have five popularity of Boston figures
its brakes first of all on the Patriots
is Brady Gronk he
correct Brady's number one clunk but you
got Larry Bird you got you know Bobby
Orr you gotta live it yeah Pete you got
a bunch of there's a bunch of them but
Gronkowski will he's still playing but
in folklore he'll go down as a great
Boston sports hero as much as you can't
stand Brady
everybody loves Gronkowski while he was
out on the field playing the Super Bowl
which he came back from the concussion
protocol to do quite two touchdowns just
miles away from Gillette Stadium his
[ __ ] house was robbed oh really no in
Massachusetts in messages so that's
[ __ ] up because they knew those
[ __ ] professionals are like this
guy's playing the Super Bowl everybody
knows you'll be done I mean to happen to
a league - for the wall he was right in
the World Series I mean that's but and
world's it's it's [ __ ] up to be robbed
it's just his pregnant girl was home
that's [ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up but I
wanted to pose this question to you cuz
this is another sort of thing I just was
talking on the brand-new I am rapport
stereo podcast who's they call it stares
who's that the I am right you're just
jealous the eyebrows everybody's which
is dropping out of the kids stereo
podcast but surrounds us so I thought
that that was just rude and vile I mean
his crib is a couple of miles away from
Gillette Stadium
right there in Boston savages do you
think that guy who robbed Gronkowski's
house while he's playing the Super Bowl
is a more of a piece of [ __ ] or the
Philadelphia Eagles fan who after the
game actually ate horseshit on videotape
who do you think is more of a so here's
why I like here's why I like the guy who
ate the horseshit ready
you like him because he lost a bet and
he honored it probably no way this is a
celebration
no he's just so happy and they Dechaine
just like the guy in Cleveland Cleveland
yeah I wish it was a better he was so
excited when he goes fly no surprises
rabbits he didn't he didn't just do that
you know I also bring that video up Jim
he went down to the [ __ ] looked it
meticulously picked the right pile a big
nugget eight to [ __ ] and like he he
didn't bat a [ __ ] eye yeah and it
happened in Cleveland that's when the
Cleveland Cavaliers want to find
personnel from Cleveland in Cleveland
but they are never gonna win anything
here's a problem with Philly I'm at your
question a problem with Philly is
they're wrecking the town they're
literally [ __ ] them oh yeah a fairly
fans yeah but what kind of ways have to
celebrate what's wrong with you
act like you've been there before I know
it's been since the 70s what [ __ ] sake
exactly Phillies got Chicago when I'm
gonna eat [ __ ] watch this no no one's
gotta be on bath salts yeah yeah he's
high as [ __ ] hey guys he wants to
impress like watch how he goes down
first his scarf dips into it I'm not mad
as Randall Cunningham Jersey but Randall
Cunningham is ashamed of this guy right
now oh my god yeah yeah but you know it
look at those discard the scar didn't
Rob anybody smelly he's picking it
there's many piles of for sure that's
horse or that dog horse shoe mad horses
just hay and then he ate it yeah I don't
know that's a close call me eatin and
spit it out no homeboy like was like
down like he was bad about it when you
were doing that you doing it just for
your bros cuz no girls he like damn
doing really gotta eat the [ __ ] I gotta
suck your dick
yep that's more horse poo breath now
that that guy's fine
he's kind of a mess but the guy who
robbed Gronk is a very he person he's a
scumbag but he's a flower opportunist
not really for not really people do it
all the time they do it to comedians
have any Kevin Hart when he's on the
road happens to people all the time they
know we gotta go [ __ ] off social media
well you say sometimes sometimes you
can't and you know it's cool like why
don't you come in and dress this way
you're like no one's ever gonna think I
want to rob right no never
first of all a smart lady to say because
you're so much picked up yeah you can't
dress like that dude loosen me man
hi bums me out I gotta [ __ ] like what
kind of like are those are you going to
the ballet in them shits like did you
come from ballet what this is for this
is for our class mobility with my rap
that's gonna bum me out too he has this
trainers daughter cut his hair and his a
mullet he's a mullet in the back you
Mina's daughter come here do you need
money I will lend you money for her 20
bucks I want to keep I want to keep my
[ __ ] a little bit long 20 bucks
I'm keeping my [ __ ] a little longer
why'd you let your trainers Dora country
first of all first of all she's an
excellent
it was just that I didn't have a lot of
time so I was like just just leave the
ranch hey just leave it leave the back
is this on the top it gave already in
the back date cuz you know I kept my own
hair and I go you gotta help me out you
do cut your own hair dude really
i I have a weird condition you know
people are cutters or they pick like
Birds pick their feathers if I'm alone
in a hotel room which I am all the time
eating it all the time his hair I'll
start cutting my hair so what I got look
too much hair on my body
in fact it even to hit those eyebrows up
but you're right we're saying everything
and today you guys never spent like a
like you know hotels shared a room well
no no but we've been around he came in
and saw me doing deep yoga naked and I
had a bottle of baby oil and he was like
what the [ __ ] is going on with you Brian
I saw everything he was bent over
downward dog he's [ __ ] in my face
yeah but I stayed I stay open supple and
my body is always humming what are you
doing I mean nothing I would assure you
Brett what are you doing I didn't wear
this what is that what does that say
it's just 50 you know I had the 40's
here now it has the the clover
yeah the Irish clovers 50 no cos the
last time I was here we made a [ __ ]
bet my man
you weren't here just me and Brendan
[ __ ] kick-ass show
all right though we made a bet homie and
I gotta clean your house your
[ __ ] my house is big and it's
got high [ __ ] sin you're showing off
a lot right now dude you take it easy
he's gotta clean your house yeah that's
gonna dust and clean up I'm gonna have
that [ __ ] in a thong give him
some baby oil and you're gonna clean
that [ __ ]
[ __ ] I mean I want that [ __ ]
shiny oh you're not leaving until
they're shining out [ __ ] shine
rats house like a diamond how many how
many bets have you paid off since your
big Conor McGregor he's gonna win no no
no I won all my bets because I said he'd
win round sir oh that was he won four
rounds did you win that that that you
bet like 4 K yes that was smart
how much did you win on it a bunch of
money a bunch of money do you bet
nah but I that was your own bed I
wouldn't you bet when you know so much
about sports you do fantasy
you know it's because to me if I think
if you get into the money like as much
as I I love the sports and and I love
talking [ __ ] and I love the five dollars
in the twenty dollars and maybe a
hundred for me even with fantasy or a
fight like it's gotta be fun like
anything I think it's just stressful if
you put that much money on it it takes
the fun I agree takes the fun out of it
and if they lose you're all mine one
sporting event that got you the most
heated cut Conor McGregor made 100
percent well know what's the word event
that was said of all the sporting events
that I've been emotionally involved with
and and and we build up to it that got
the most heated because I was to me and
I only we talked about this it was like
I'm going for the boxer period I don't I
don't it was like it was just them I
feel like it was like MMA for sold box
and heads and then even at the fight was
race which I had to fight and rap just
yell and yell and I'm upset because you
know the way to then did my crap I was
at the weigh-in I mean the for me the
racial overtones there was violation and
I was like you know I'm not a Mayweather
fan in boxing obviously I don't you know
respect and support the [ __ ] he's done
and all that's a but like I was like for
this fight you're not gonna come in here
and beat one of the best boxers ever
it's not happening the best ever
happening but now you see they they keep
harping to each other now Floyd wants to
fight MMA he doesn't want to fight a my
mate well I have some ties to Showtime
and I know
Floyd was flying to New York to speak
with Espinoza bout fighting MMA Brandon
Chris Chris cyborgs trainer girlfriend
Chris side works trainers girlfriend who
also trains MMA would beat Floyd
Mayweather NMA be a bad idea for anybody
he can't fight anybody you shouldn't put
him with a professional fight you should
wear the professional fighters
girlfriend it's very strange is that
Fighting's thinkin I don't believe you I
have no idea he just can't help himself
no he could fight McGregor again in a
boxing match in in in England and I'd be
the smartest play fight McGregor in
Ireland or something like this do you
think since you're so in the know that
you're you just said iron espinosa you
just drop the big name there so
well I'm just saying you didn't think he
was ever gonna happen come in with us 15
oh sure okay but see what you could buy
if you listen I read um don't but but if
do you do you think that Conor McGregor
ever tipped the referee for not letting
him get knocked the [ __ ] out no you
don't think you ever do like no I
actually I think the referee hurt Conor
McGregor in that fight because that
referee was a no-bullshit wouldn't like
Conor time-up wouldn't do any of that
stuff if you notice usually the like
guys kind of worked out themselves as
soon as they would touch you go break it
up but it was because honor Kip see and
I'm gonna kick you and I'm like and they
were like well he was joking but the
last thing we got was a so biased
towards box in which offseason boxing
match I know who wouldn't be but he was
so biased to make sure that Conor's
advantage which being in the clinch
being the bigger guy didn't happen he
took that away which is you know good on
Floyd but he was so biased towards that
I just feel like that ref he did his job
but he did his job but he also do his
job by saving him from getting knocked
the [ __ ] either out of the ring or out
well he was in trouble in that in that
night the thing about that fight in
Hines is like you can ago he hit me
whether we win no boxing you know a
little Baba Bach support Mayweather and
always 49 fights
he never want a guy down what he walked
down the bigger tougher not only in the
rounds which is why he lost his earlier
rounds he's trying to feel him out yes
yeah which was a game but it was a non
contest but as far as the reaction
people got to me you [ __ ] race
traitor have a [ __ ] Jew root for the
you you and a straight race traitor you
rooting for this n-word you [ __ ] I
mean wow
it was it was it was to me I was like it
was like a wake-up calls like wow I'll
say this though I went into it not being
the biggest Floyd fan I've said preciate
him for what he does in the ring and
then being around him and talking to him
I became such a big fan not what he does
you know with his social life and
personal life what was impressive just
his business savvy and how much of a
leader he was and how he knew exactly
was going on at all times right camera
here this came here I need this here
you're gonna be here here's this this is
like when you were called everything and
then we sit down he's just such a
cerebral dude when it comes to
entertainment and how he looks and he's
very well-spoken even though some say
can't read like he's just a beast man
yeah I walked away going holy [ __ ] I had
people think they know what they see in
Floyd Mayweather on this 24/7 whatever
you know he's it's a bit supercilious
it's a straight person and so is Connors
so is a great government I'm sure he is
and they're both great [ __ ] talkers and
they're both [ __ ] great promoters and
it turned into ignoring like it's
actually like you sure how could they
not like each other and like made crazy
money off each other great he was the
perfect opponent for this weird fight
for Floyd to make this type of money
what's what's what do you think is gonna
be the next legit cross-cultural whether
it's boxing or UFC Usain like them doing
that that's a serious
you got tuberculous makan seat oh you
got tuberculosis why are you coughing so
is that blood no man what happened did
oh you're not well did you have a flu
did you get to stuff the flu cuz I had
that failure at the bird flu that [ __ ]
had me down for two weeks yeah a seat
you guys did you have a flu everybody
nobody wants to admit this no I don't
have the flu at New York swine flu idea
it's just New York Jew sounds like the
old bacon long bad what do you think
they'll be the next weather it's a no
not they're just boxing animation I
don't want to see that again I don't see
it either look like in terms of like
what do you think the next legit big UFC
fight will be like I mean where it's
like people that aren't the normal fans
will watch we don't have one right now
yeah I think I know Brock Lesnar's gonna
be a free agent sometime this year
probably one if probably be in jail for
for fighting the guy on steroids or cuz
I saw with a deadly weapon the steroids
are a deadly weapon you'd be the only
thing where it cross over but you know
you have the super fight with DC and
steep a and then yet TJ Mighty Mighty
Mouse but those aren't like that won't
that's not that crossed I won't no that
won't cross over to pop culture these
john jones gonna fight UFC again yes
I bet by the end of the year I bet is
Nate Diaz never gonna fight Conor
McGregor um I don't know if that fight
ever goes anywhere they could do it
whenever but Nate Diaz will fight
Woodley next
Tyron Woodley Oh what do you figure that
fight I think Woodley beats him I [ __ ]
with Nate Diaz so hard I love that
[ __ ] dude yeah he's right is he been
on the show no cuz he said I'll come if
he's no no here he and I are you guys
are kin to my show in San Diego we hang
you do did a little show me a little
boxing Diddy yeah would he show you
we're in a bag my show you how you sold
show me a video of it I felt sick yeah
yeah just yeah they showed me a video
you look what Brian's doing they deals
my god damn it Nate Diaz is so ashamed
of himself for even like [ __ ] now he
was like you move I'm so excited
I just hope Nate fights again I think
him waiting around for Conor I'm now see
it's a big payday I don't see how Connor
wants to do that right that was a war
Masada was about 55 for sure yeah yeah
that's a huge question 8 what what is 65
he's a 7 year 55 err but he lives better
for Bull Connor Fort Lamy where 175 he
was you know he blew a dinner like 70
only likes to fight guys that he pick on
older guys huh
McGregor I want to fight a guy was 40 oh
you're Connor hater that's what you I oh
you know I'm not even hate on a guy like
that with five years ago was unwell
thing ah you know so he says so he says
no I'm telling me that's real for us so
he says he doesn't come from money so he
says
Brendan but then he just like so yeah no
I love as a UFC fighter I've always
loved him I voted for Nate Diaz to beat
him both times but I just for somebody
like that like he's a [ __ ] talker he
talks his [ __ ] you sell tickets sell
tickets he's good he's good for is a
showman he's a showman
I think he's selling out too early what
do you mean like he's 29 years old you
don't want to fight fight anybody else
anymore it's it's tough gig mailing a
hundred million dollars in the bank
right Who am I was also remember he was
also thinking about retiring before all
this should happen it's a tough gig he
was already on D he was already like I
was out of the gym in his coach was like
man you got a offered to fight in UFC
get back in the gym
fine he didn't answer the phone like he
didn't answer the call like how do you
know he didn't answer the call we talked
about it also we have a phrase you say I
didn't know him at Google
yeah well we also have a timeshare with
the other elites it that's how you
request free rap yeah you think your boy
LeBrons gonna take that meeting with the
Golden State Warriors I will say no if
he does I'm die we'll quit watching my
show for the red line why it's so [ __ ]
up it might as well be NBA 2k where you
just put all your own age it might as
well be the MBA West all start all for
story I mean the all the best place not
gonna
I heard don't stay in this is what Jalen
Rose said he goes hate to tell you guys
spoke to people at they're gonna state
worries they're not interested no I'm
not taking them they don't need him and
LeBron need he's not taking that me
LeBron comes Ellie I think so LeBron
scum Nellie they got the the bankroll
the the Clippers have the highest he
wants to be in here but he's not going
to want to go to Lakers and I'd love to
see him in Lakers but they need they
need to bring him and someone of another
big name but what wise not gonna come
alone he's no no no I'm here to win a
championship
he's getting older it's gonna stop at
some point for LeBron
he's 30-something looks every bit at 45
what he came in the league looking 45
really old
he's younger now but he's got an old man
face it's amazing his hair is like SIA
and beer his whole grill like he came
into the league okay looking I think he
looks younger now than he died he was 19
yeah yeah oh but I Gregg Odom just looks
60 he looks like Morgan Freeman
yeah he was like young he was 20 but I
mean I listen the LeBron [ __ ] is so
these come to LA though he's I think
he's definitely not staying in Cleveland
he ain't staying in Cleveland it's a
[ __ ] show there right yeah he I mean it
should show a little Isaiah they go
what's wrong with the team he goes as
soon as it going gets rough we all got
our separate ways we don't come together
we go we literally go our own ways it's
a it's a it's they're messed up he's in
for a surprise though it comes to the
West man yes every necklace does not
play around no yeah deal with Houston
the Spurs
I heard he's in Sunday's okay see ya you
say you heard they're gonna throw all
these names out there with you you know
some make sense but see I came on the
Spurs I I would have to say as much as I
can't stand them I would be
nightmare if in my [ __ ] Popovich
Popovich and then don't forget why liner
and whoever other guys they they they
plug in their to plug and play in
probably in play situation right that's
what my problem they're in any place
they plug them in you play the coach no
plug in the proper though I kept in
Miami right in Cleveland he can do
whatever he wants he's basically the
coach yes with Popovich you go now you
pop is the guy who's he's got what on
it's got a volcanic temper what's his
first night just read a book on him that
by the same his name is Gregg Popovich
and the Spurs are the most winning his
team in American history I just read a
whole thing called the culture code
about highly effective groups and they
showcased that dude here's what he'll do
every year so he'll take his team when
they lost and yeah I'll have them
sometimes they're gonna date me on her
watch practice
yeah and instead they'll have he's about
cook team cohesion they'll watch like a
documentary on the 1968 Civil Rights
unrest but the Oilers love that well
know what they do because then they'll
have like a debate and I said what do
you think about it what do you think
about it then they all have meals
together so he'll find the best
restaurant they all go out to eat and
then he'll choose the wine and
everything else and then at the end of
every season everybody gets a menu from
every restaurant they ate and and the
wine that they the label of the wine
what's it in a book it's called the
culture code what's it called our code
here the culture code here is just would
follow my lead because you're a beta
follow the Alpha follow the only a meal
with Rabb's yeah I paid I did the
[ __ ] Julie page we first I ate I pay
you saw me downstairs get my sandwich
and you showed up right after I paid
today we go you know yeah but you could
pay the $13 O'Brien has alligator ups
listen no he had a daughter cuts is here
instead of paying for her [ __ ] got
cuts is here himself do that be honest
with you Brennan is Brennan doesn't pay
and I've been through your meal know
there was like nine dollars when I here
we go here we go we were in Vegas
nothing like we could add sushi fans you
didn't hit me up nothing no you were I
was working non-stop when you had on
those [ __ ]
those shoes
yeah you're done Iguchi [ __ ] like but
like they were like Prince boots yeah
yeah but you were wearing them did you
buy a new house is that why you were on
all the house hunter things I was on the
house that was one house hunter it's not
about 50 who were that joana joana and
what games he know he's I was on real
house no I was on Beverly Hills of um
[ __ ] I know I go ahead no no I was on
whatever the [ __ ] show is like the
house thing on Bravo and and I was good
I was actually going to a million dollar
listing million dollar listings Beverly
Hills okay and and I went in there and
and I was going to look in the house and
they said you can't go look at this
particular house Friday at 2:00
I said why they said what they're
filming million dollar Beverly Hills I
said [ __ ] I love that [ __ ] I
want to go in the show so I would you
crashed the show
well they said come on and it's never
crashing the cameras and I will you
really get looking at that buying that
huh yeah but it wasn't for me one day I
could see where was it at it was like in
mid-wilshire area but the guy kept
saying um you know the house is whatever
let's say it was like 1.5 million
dollars and he goes and we're walking
through and the guy said you know if I
bought the house I would do this to it
and if I bought the house I would tear
this down and I said but you're not
paying your [ __ ] littlez three
million yeah yeah I'm paying 1.5
basically for a piece of [ __ ] that
really needs a whole lot la by the
rejuvenation you start with 1 1 million
dollars that laugh at you yeah I think
it's better here than in New York City
force New York City yes there's more
opportunities out here a little bit but
you're right you can still get up it's
better Manhattan is [ __ ] yeah yeah bad
and even Brooklyn is terrible yep
dinasty yep
terrible yep you look tired Bryant brain
no brain not tired not tired no I have a
backpack of energy I have what's called
an extra backpack of stamina brother and
on a forced march 12 you're [ __ ] way
behind and this is me oh my lord
Mike come on Mike Mike I want you to
keep your eyes on my belt loop don't
take them off my belt loop
I want you smelling my [ __ ] to hold
up this hill and then finally I take my
belt and I wrap it around your [ __ ]
head and I tell
you I dragged you up because you're
complaining the whole [ __ ] time
you're just a dog leash you I got it and
then the other thing is because of your
skin is not built for the Sun no you're
you're a [ __ ] bright your tomato as I
say Hamada your tomato Mata your tomato
protect you against sunstroke and your
lungs exam outing and your feet and
everything else just don't have the
stamina rap I want you smelling my
[ __ ] the whole way up grab you by the
ears and look you in the eye go that's
my badge oh boy
let's do this I got a I got a fashion
you a hat you knew a hat out of [ __ ]
palm fronds wrap I'm always in New York
man what's up dawg never take you have
you have you read it as you ever taking
out new you're not [ __ ] how often are
this I'm causing their car luck with
your show time constant time March I'm
there in April I'm the non-stop what are
you doing here March uh shooting some
stuff for show - ok I'll see you there
I'll see you then what I hang with fear
Oh been there done that
[ __ ] fighter in the key won't see he
doesn't stop it's the fight in like
question mark it's like really like
fighter and like you got to get like I
like a little velcro thing you could
just replace it it's like it's like
going to dinner with a history teacher
like toss let me on the plane
I've never flown on a plane you go boy
Justin palm fronds huh get any more
water I'm not putting any water on your
tongue I'll speak your mouth oh there
you go that's your water now smell my
ass oh and does Hellboy
Oh southern accent no I become a drill
sergeant went on a forced march a lot
before I got to get your feet OH
Rock holding the old Romero your two
lovers are fighting I know and I'm gonna
get to it but hold on grab what shows do
you have going on right now
a typical for Netflix I'm get ready
start season 2 and then I had white
famous for Showtime which was how did
that key cancel no clue
cuz it I thought it was jewels it was a
good show I had power behind a chair
James Jaime front ferrule wrap wanna do
some power but you see yeah you see you
never know
you know why you know why I think
because Showtime has some killer shows
right now this was a killer show I know
but you're competing with Smith you can
be in with what's what's the other big
shows you got Ray Donovan
that's that's not gonna be on the air
anymore that's that's gonna end soon I
know but you gots milf and then what's
sort of the big um the huge yes with the
guy from shameless
yeah I mean you're competing with that
but you're not competing with you got a
build that listen oh and then you have
you have a shot dying up here the shy
yeah yeah listen but you you gotta have
more shows I don't know what happened I
thought it was good I loved working with
Showtime I loved I loved white Fey my
brother loved billions to much better
watch yo man you got homeland billion I
know they got a lot going share what's
Showtime show where you one Brian I've
done Californication you [ __ ]
oh I don't like your attitude you got
decks on Californication is like 99 when
we don't know bro I'm not here and if I
can go through my resume but just know
that I do just fine I'm too busy on the
Goldbergs okay yo Brian spin-off waiting
to hear best I know we'll see it's so
nerve-wracking right not it's a you know
how we tell you're numb oh don't listen
to this [ __ ] don't care no he does
how can i as soon as we wrap he's like
what do you think am i doing out doing
that what do you think this is after the
show he's a first-timer you got here
know what these are the noises do you
ever wake up in the middle of a like oh
that's what you do when you face [ __ ]
one times twin peaks' still on here's
the thing we're going to in Peaks now
rap FaceTime me today talking [ __ ] you
mum you [ __ ] better not be late
how's it coming man everytime I come it
[ __ ] late
every single time it's so rules trash
its disrespect but training my training
schedule you know training Jack just
banged up 50 percent a rabbit me relate
all time on set would you have a job
hell no I know he's not late for the
Goldbergs or his other show not only
that with if don't sign off everybody oh
that with your imagine him on a set like
around all their like legitimate people
I can't no I get serious but I know you
you by acting you give me anything right
now I'll do something [ __ ] we're not
your craft I can do crazy drama right
now I can put it on like that what what
dude I do like what like I don't know
anything dude
anything be like a mom be like okay baby
I'll be a white rapper you're on white
famous you're the white rapper there's
there's no white rappers on white do I
know the role they should have had this
show and it got cancelled yo yo I need
some wrap up in this [ __ ] right
here yeah yes that's pretty good
sterling Nate he knows I need some rat
y'all need some wrap up in this
[ __ ] right here is that I need
20 Sarat I need to wrap up in my phone
right I'm about nobody off I'm nobody
that's it we wouldn't it definitely
happens get hey he was in a couple
episodes y'all see this was talented man
American made the most talent he's one
of most talented people I've ever been
around who know Jamie Foxx yes he he's
so gifted and his stand up his early
stand up all our [ __ ] he can see if he
comes on your podcast you'll you'll suck
him off like right yes I will but but he
only gave rogue in 30 minutes but did he
talk ish yeah well he only gave Robin 30
minutes she not me me none is that
everybody and their [ __ ] and their
landscaper on not one [ __ ] time you
know a Joe wrote me I'll talk to him
talk to him but I don't think you want
me to go on Joe Rogan why well I don't
know
no no joke text Joe right now I with
Rappaport he doesn't know why you've had
everybody and their [ __ ] maker behind
a college I do for him
everybody in their gynecologist has been
on Joe Rogan show two or three four
times but I'm not going on there for
four [ __ ] he'll Arab everybody and
their gynecologist
has been on [ __ ] Joe Rogan show
except me Joe where the [ __ ] are you at
my man what is the problem jump smoke
and Joe Rogan smoke and Joe smoking Joe
Rogan damn funny chill dude
wait what was I gonna say you reminded
me of what oh yeah
yo you got [ __ ] on the bottom of your
shoes that's not that's gone are you God
yeah hey you want a water I gave a
dollar I'll pay for the water do we take
a piss break real quick while you get to
low income let's take a piss break let's
take a sex break no no do ten more
minutes are you take a piss break in
that round
was this is the kind of [ __ ] wait we're
back from a piss break we have to rough
up Callum look at our sex thread ours
mean yeah because no grappler cause
we're some time for me Brian
I didn't yeah Brian and also have a
[ __ ] snack ready for wrap snack you
want and then wrap goes I just want to
[ __ ] so I didn't say that you can make
text 11:30 tomorrow don't be [ __ ]
late tomorrow that I said he says that's
on me then you go shut up and then he
goes wear something tight and don't be
late to me yeah and I didn't say that
and brain goes Brandon goes deal and
then and then what happened then you go
here
what happened lipstick boy you're
[ __ ] late yeah I'm a little late okay
and here we are
I now we're into it now you let me just
backtrack to where this all started
because I'm not doing how how long have
we been going an hour I'm not doing one
of these [ __ ] three hour no we uh
we'll do this then we'll do current
events and you can get the hook out he
but but but last year your top five
guests top three gathers D'Elia got the
hold against cliff nope Theo von nope
the other one I like him he was talking
[ __ ] to me on doing this and I said feel
listen you have him need to get together
the Netflix special was great does it
mean that you're a great guest on
fighter in the kid and ended like and
that's not a disrespect that's just a
fact who else was there was a young kid
Tony Hinchcliffe know young young I
asked him what is it the New York Ida's
impression well no he's a legit actor
singer but he's a singer you can sing
and see his ass up like what maybe went
home from Broadway or he's been on pitch
perfect I don't go a new song of voice
of branch on the trolls okay great so he
was here he was like I'm gonna be in the
fire though the guest of the year he
also sings a big brown intro give a [ __ ]
what he sings he's handsome
big brown eye intro yes that's not
something like you should like [ __ ]
go around and be proud about oh wow rap
like I'm just saying so he was another
was like I'm the guest of the year I'm
Skyler just pushing for and I said a guy
named but I remember I swear I said a
[ __ ] kid named Skyler with dimples
will never be better than me this is the
sorry sorry you know way in a way you
have seniority and in a way he's not
does bring you the shoes to go but we
can't get to give it to you every year
rap same thing with Thalia
daliyah's feelings work is not
just grab his takes it'll just take well
maybe we should call the finally kid
rapport Award no you're gonna win but
it's not fun if you you know you awkward
daliyah - but your friend the guest of
the year Brady boom you play you can't
win every Super Bowl I can't give it to
every time you're there I'll give you
that you're the Brady of the podcast I'm
gonna cuz I'm coming here early
obviously I'll be the front-runner by
out by a long shot but I'm gonna come
back at the second half of the year I'll
probably make like a guest appearance
for in the middle of summer but it
really comes down to like October
November December because that's when
the voting starts and I'm gonna come
backs like the Gleeman I'm gonna take a
[ __ ] and then leave Oh can't you [ __ ]
I'm gonna take a [ __ ] on this - yeah so
did that he can't run in my house one
time and he goes he just goes hey guys
hey what's up yeah when he looked at my
fridge and then he goes look I use
bathroom took a [ __ ] in my bathroom and
see it and laughs you know I know you
know we're doing now rap it's very rare
we have a guest these days unless we
enjoy the person and we gel with them we
just do me and Brian imagine [ __ ] right
what do you always have ghetto I just
started having I know you should never
have Ken how you always having guests
like Oh check it out me and [ __ ] you
always do my chain Ian Martin no let's
talk about the old glory day I'm a
Dallas you don't get oatmeal on top five
words every week top five sports every
week all oh yeah you do you Jeff
sponsors donut do I have sponsors well I
mean right listen this is my rep they're
a half hour
listen legit you about 20 minutes live
legit the iron reports are your pocket
Godfather's a kid yeah but the iron
report stereo pocket I want to let the
people figure out watch your work choose
your words what they think is a better
podcast you could listen to both I'm not
saying it's not like you don't have to
pick one I'm still gonna come on this
show for sure more people than this and
you know big duel now it's okay you come
from barstool you have to help from
there's other podcasts out there that
are really popular doesn't mean they're
good you know what else is joke TV
dinners doesn't mean it's [ __ ] good
so there's a bunch of pockets they're
right there at the number one doesn't
mean they're good doesn't mean they're
truly enjoy doesn't mean they're funny /
buoyed dwarf you
right no I don't think not he doesn't
say well toy does well alright should we
do something with you fights we talk
about the okay okay alright the first
one the showrunners of Game of Thrones
you know these guys right those are my
boys yeah yeah they're gonna be writing
some Star Wars movies oh wow
those guys are so smart did I ever tell
you what happened with this rap you've
heard this story B so I was on I was on
a plane cuz we shared the same agent
we're on a plane going to the UFC in
Brewster Asian bro
Todd Feldman look him up do you research
so what agency CA okay only the best so
I'm on a plane on a private plane with
these guys and with the crew from Always
Sunny in Philadelphia and these guys
start talking they go we're filming in
Ireland I go I'm be out there I'm
actually doing a bunch of statement
Thrones I didn't know this and I go [ __ ]
oh he's sunny filled everything me and I
really guys really sold out man he is
getting big time and these two go what
no no we do Game of Thrones like oh [ __ ]
I didn't watch Game of Thrones at the
time so I mean I talk to him a little
bit their brilliant minds brilliant yeah
yeah as soon as I got home I went
through all seven seasons like a month
obsessed with it now I've Game of
Thrones t-shirt they're amazing I'm
trying to hope so brilliant I respect
them both would would would would jump
at the opportunity to work with them I
don't [ __ ] with Game of Thrones at all
have you seen it
yes I don't [ __ ] with lightning dragon
can't see my bird it was like watching
episodes I've watched the show I know
I'm in the minority and I know probably
like talking about Janet Jackson is
dangerous talking about Game of Thrones
just really Danger Danger I don't [ __ ]
with Game of Thrones I don't [ __ ] with
dungeon dragon I didn't even attitude
hey B was that not the same exact give
me those rap hasn't actually seen in
that used to have and he's made a
decision oh you watched one you like
dragon and the girl with chains I was
shame I got Dinklage okay [ __ ] my guy
Dinklage no no you gotta be careful now
everything did you see his commercial
he's rapping yeah that was a little
classic the Busta Rhymes
more no Freder Peters funny as hell I've
only met him in pass here's that to
complete ever come on the show he's a
comic no never come on Peter a long time
for you don't Peter a long time yet
don't call Peter though you know just
gone by his character name cuz nope
Luigi them no I just had to know from
your Peter Dean could you do a [ __ ]
movie with him as he would he's asked
these days nobody
so we he's such a good friend he's like
all we did theater in New York and in
the New York days well what you do and
why does he come a far we didn't
actually do theater together we did
theater separately but he's always been
a good friend we've always been he's a
big deal you have you seen why not his
daughter his daughters regular size and
you know he's hold her hand and you know
yeah he's not very if he's killed a
funny guy he's got a great sense of
he'll yeah yeah just um just be easy
wraps told me to be easy we were taking
in more troublemaker me or you for your
mouth that based on what you told me
weird neck it [ __ ] neck right now
we're getting close talking off camera
line because you're both fair-minded
people and I think we live in a fin
tyrannical times speech is dead and I
know I know but you got a bit you know
what though that being said I agree with
what you said we're in show business and
it's business show and you gotta watch
it what you think is contextually ruined
you can be ruined by what you say and I
and so another word three guys that talk
[ __ ] yeah and so in other words
literally are you just dead free speech
one of the most treasured things in the
Constitution is dead and that has it
harder than anyone because hope there be
something going on and hook it on there
would be the first one I see on there
like this is my thought on Brady
Jackson I basically said Janet Jackson
she's a popular as she was when she was
[ __ ] the most popular thing in the
world that she was so what's the problem
I'm [ __ ] but why did you why did you
go after whose because Justin Timberlake
when he performed it was the whole thing
about the Nipplegate and why isn't she
so mean when she had a birdie she's
moved away she's barely performed like
well she did this out I'll shut needs no
introduction of course I [ __ ] love
Janet Jackson here at the halftime show
not now you know but like that doesn't
mean she's not a [ __ ] icon on a legend
and all that stuff but like right now
she clearly hasn't focused into as she
she did nor does she nor does she
- she's a [ __ ] she's the top of the
top but you racist white [ __ ]
how dare you say something about this
you little dick white [ __ ]
and when I say call Jewish people racist
and white when when when you know
anybody who does that or Julia Jewish
men are always lumped in with white men
and if you actually look at the history
the jury used to say if you want to talk
about a group people that were killed
like systematically throughout their
entire kill I mean six million of them
in bond say kill disappear terrible
tragedies and I'm not saying you should
what I'm saying is that we are breaking
into these I believe that the debate and
and the conversation is being controlled
by the two lunatic fringe is on the left
and the right and it's up to people in
the middle who are sensible to say [ __ ]
you guys you know what I meant and if
you don't you're stupid right and you're
like I'm allowed to speak I'm allowed to
be funny I'm allowed to be I'm allowed
to have an opinion I'd love to see
something any in and also um not be
appropriate it doesn't mean I'm a [ __ ] or
nerd and castaway and Shane don't
[ __ ] uh there were that show our our
it's entire cultural [ __ ] our democracy
our liberal democracy is based on the
idea that you must respect and even at
times listen to those you disagree with
and those that you even find after did
you ever does it ever bother you on
social media those negative comments
does ever get to you it bothers me with
the onslaught like when they start
lights non-stop like gang up on like we
do with the onslaught it bothers me um
because I know it bothers me for that
but but but I look at like like the
Janet Jackson thing the same way I like
what like the three times that I've sort
of had they would be like the Janet
Jackson fans which was hashtag black
Twitter which doesn't speak for every
black person it doesn't speak for every
black person on Twitter nah
okay it's just it's just a little mob of
like you know a few hundred
[ __ ] um but I equate it to the
Cleveland Cavaliers fans when I talk
about LeBron James like the same [ __ ]
like oh your Cleveland Cavaliers fan
stuff Utah [ __ ] what you're talking
about exactly what else yet chin exactly
alright check this out this is a messed
up case of a student having sex for
theirs
teacher having sex with her students
that was the teachers the teacher she's
22 years old and the studio was getting
hotter and hotter a student was what 18
nothing wrong with that but because he
was a student she's facing three counts
of sexual assault even though he's 18
yeah because because he's a student and
I yeah but it is that is that in the
rule book in that rule University really
yeah but the parents even the parents of
the student are saying please don't
press charges on her they're in love
yeah that Barco and their son is you
know what the cool the parents and the
parents are actually met while they were
in college it was a student really love
each other let the senator people alone
did you ever have an affair with a to a
teacher walnuts I never had one even
come after me
they'd never be real-ass em never get
the [ __ ] is sexist danger you want my
call with terrible though to huh
my teachers were all warlocks never had
one that even even cross she is gorgeous
that's so [ __ ] up that they're doing
that to her by the way she could face up
if it's a sex is sex is sex is more
dangerous than any disease now sex well
if you need us to go your bills with you
or anything what else these are not that
great but okay so a woman want that huge
grand prize lottery Wow for five hundred
sixty million a little one of the things
is you have to you can't be a anonymous
you have to show your name
so she's suing them to try to make her
name anonymous yeah that's stupid why do
you have to show your name because we
got a lawyer
no I'm saying that yes they should not
show their name all his family goes oh
sweet let us get your money they're
gonna figure it out when you go from
living in a [ __ ] trailer park to a
goddamn mansion and you not you just
disappeared like I took a new job yeah
yeah I'm out and I actually the way I
got out of here is on my private [ __ ]
jet yeah see a helicopter I'm done with
you bye I got 500 600 you have [ __ ] you
money no I don't every close know not to
[ __ ] you money like I'm still a young
guy I'm young yeah oh don't get don't
say yeah okay
getting there I'm going to have [ __ ]
money here everywhere when you [ __ ] you
money it's a different what about you
money the 20 mil in the bank that's
that's [ __ ] you money I think yeah you
need that [ __ ] techno 20 mil it depends
on your lifestyle right Milford for the
three of us [ __ ] you money
I don't want email no but I'm not buying
[ __ ] nine hundred ninety five nine
thousand nine hundred fifty dollar Gucci
jack see now is the time to have [ __ ]
you money when you're your guyses age
because you've had all the fun
mimei not gonna go out and go crazy
you're aged aged aged what are you
talking about bro like you guys have
lived like you like to get the money and
buy gold chains and all your friends and
maybe I'm gonna have odd trousers cuz no
one says you need a little bit more cuz
you wear those [ __ ] boots and your
Gucci che use offender huh
not really most of the stuff a lot of
stuff you see I get for free but I'm
saying when you dress up like when I saw
you for the Grammys you had that purple
velvet jacket on I have a stylist he
takes here that I'll maybe you looked I
mean you look I was I was like whoa do
you know he is my man you attach it
there no let me see the Oscars the
Oscars I'm gonna give you a hint it's
yellow what it's yellow it's yellow ish
it's good yeah he's a cutie-pie
he likes to dress up um I don't know
what would you do with five thirty what
would that what would that change your
life if I were 30 mil what would you do
like let's say you like you could like
literally live wherever you want but
live in LA you live in LA okay so you
you'd buy another home in LA yeah a
pride pride buy a home in Malibu buy
place in Hollywood just cuz want like a
like an apartment right I just so I can
chill the pride buy a place in San Diego
that's about it see me well you don't
you stay over here like that you know
you know I have a chopper like Black
Mamba
so you know the only thing I know is the
the way to travel I think Warren Buffett
said that to me too I I hate the
airports man me too it's such a sweet
travels privately and five sikri would
you live still would you stand it though
yeah you have to yes die and just you
have to it's oh yeah nothing would
change and you know it's crazy if you
had the 560 million your stand-up
wouldn't get any better
hey man Mike Mike you know what those
you're right you might be right because
all right oh wow don't do that
burn me that bad dude don't get burned
ants don't do it burned ants like that
don't push the money I slammed like you
just burned me that guy Charlo who's
your destiny or last year follow the
voice of an angel
Charlo that's that's Yiddish first guy a
raptor are you on the same kind of
thinking as a sign field officer you
don't have sign field mine cuz he's a
billion dollars anyways they asked sign
fielding are you worried about how your
kids are gonna grow up and he woody what
do you say to your kids when they go
daddy are we rich and he turns around he
goes yeah my kids go dad don't because
he has like 300 cars right he's a
Porsche enthusiast he has so many
Porsches unbelievable and his kid goes
dad don't don't drive me a different car
every day the kids are making fun of me
and Jerry Seinfeld's like that's not my
problem ana if you want to ride to
school this is what I like to drive and
this dad and then he goes dad are we
rich Jerry sands Wranglers I am I mean
[ __ ] man he saw another planet with the
money man billion dollars who paid I
think it was 660 million dollars just a
broadcast Seinfield for three years and
then Jerry and Larry David get it back
they're borrowing it for 660 million
dollars for it they're renting it
they're leasing it somebody two minutes
that's like the seventh eighth or ninth
incarnation of the Seinfeld money that
was like the last point that's let's try
doing it too and they're like nope
somebody tell me that the friends actors
are still making 20 mil year just
because of residuals I'm sure you were
on friends yeah so tell me like [ __ ]
residuals
I get residuals but I get you residuals
like buy you a [ __ ] better twenty
would you play on that some kind of a
basketball you come in like dressed your
Tommy's all painted in coverage in no
Brian I don't know played Phoebe's
boyfriend will you get acting at the
dream lathe Phoebe's boyfriend or
episode iconic I love this huh that's an
issue walk into Air Force one that's the
first time I think anyone's caught his
hair gets blown off sorry yes such a I
can't wait to see you here the other
news about the with Trump today that
Quincy
homes Quincy Jones yeah dated Ivanka
Trump oh boy what he said well Quincy
Quincy puts it down he's gonna go and
not cuz first the age gap and then it's
a black man cuz Quincy Jones older than
her father don't dude quickly Jones I
think he's eighty nobody put it down
like Quincy Quincy Jones oh great
I know but Trump's followers are gonna
freak the [ __ ] out baby but I put it
already I had the great honor of
watching him work no I'm sure he's music
no oh women
yeah it's Quincy Jones this is real
that's real he's not making it up he
came in about like a verbatim I
interview he said all kinds of [ __ ] he
said she was a he said I think he said
in quoting I might be out of content for
her she was a bad [ __ ] she's a
fine [ __ ] wrong father though
wrong he hit her here with that thriller
dick Wow Quincy Jones theater with that
thriller Johnson I'm every 12 years
ago.you unless she must be super into
old dude 18 now you might have a chill
when he was six very when he was 64
years old I actually sat within it check
it out well he was 64 this is 20 years
ago i sat with him he was like getting
it on me though I was sitting with him
and he first of all the first thing I
said to him as I go you're in such good
shape I was just literally literally
hear me for an hour and what was it well
he took out some of the cast of Mad TV
and so and I was like the women that
were coming I was like oh they were
coming up to him yes and holy one of
this one was incredible I was trying to
pick up on her and he goes to me in the
next day he goes man you bring it in
Channel thirteen that's a rerun bro I'd
already been there and you mess up my
game because he was trying to hit on
this other girl but I was trying hit on
the girl but I didn't know if the girl
was actually hitting on him anyway long
story short he was like I said wait are
you called or a rewrite up that icy
world
he called her a reruns 23 years ago so I
like that [ __ ] but meanwhile he's he's
awesome did you know she Disney isn't
quite showing today's and gray shirt no
she danced that she dated Lincoln ed
yeah yeah she's chickenhead about a
truck that presidents or that dates
famous very successful men nothing wrong
with that they're no good man no listen
she doesn't get a pass from sleeping
with Donald
from Oh Topher Grace good guy yeah
handsome kid
she's dad mean look okay so Topher Grace
Lance Armstrong Quincy Jones the pimp of
all pimps I'm not mad at any of it no I
get it I get it a hundred percent Quincy
Jones says she has the best legs he's
ever seen and that's Quincy Jones he's
been around
yeah yeah you know what you seen some
legs up he was he's young forget to
forget the Solera no he was with Miles
Davis in the original pampies and the
Jazz era like 100 but yeah nice Jackson
era he would have we would have runners
get the 70s in the 80s that was after
Miles Davis and everything he did in
jazz dude he let's not pretend he's
good-looking guys yeah he was he was
very when he was not enough I'm saying
there that's what that's what it wants
it's pretty good for as a hey hey hey
Joe no no no let's be real Tracy's
that's not that quincy jones isn't good
looking now at 84 who can't show you a
white old guy I'll still say the same
thing young Quincy Jones I'll tell right
now dog troubles but he does hell no not
right now
Christ now chill young people question
with the put the pencil mustache in the
way Quincy Quincy you you he's the man I
know he's a dick down and now I'm a
talented uh sounds just such a bad I'm
just saying right now if I had to pick
on my father you have your Trump you'd
[ __ ] Donald Trump over now over Quincy
Jones now right now all right discovered
Oprah discovered Oprah [ __ ] over would
you [ __ ] right now yeah Quincy Jones
ring up a picture Quincy Jones questions
absolutely yeah your razor woodsy now
your racist though you click on that for
me okay okay gentlemen I'm gonna sleep
with that walrus
okay let's do that oh we just saw it
Donald we see Donald Trump Donald ooh
better shape that hands no man he's not
much he's 84 so how old Donald seven he
looks like
[ __ ] how old is down Donowitz about
anyone is he 71 I thought you said me
dude me I look I'm not they both look
like a cow I mean listen you're it's
hard to find an 84 year old guy who'd be
like I want that then I'm a guy and a 70
year old yeah you gotta like you gotta
um you gotta like give a reprimand or
referendum for everything you say and
I'm saying with my sex whatever 71 I
believe so what else y'all get the [ __ ]
up two more what else you get hour and a
half of this bro hey bro off me I'm on
pretty at the month you get me out of
here yeah you asked for an uber XXL yes
that's obnoxious dude I'm not gonna just
come down your little [ __ ] Oh get in
here you get that we got you the uber
community how many people do you like to
treat you right oh can you explain to
this I've never asked you got was to be
held on that all dude I was one time
flipping through I got my like why the
[ __ ] are the others people my ride
they're like this the community how many
people you've gone how many go for in
the car three are you going yeah yeah
how they keep going keep I'll just
cancel it keep going yeah yeah ain't
happening now seven stop I was getting
mortified all night that's like there's
a hotel that's an airport shuttles but
they stop for everybody oh my games you
know what so they gotta carry the bag
Dom well coming back to the bag hey hey
don't call me that
don't call me baggage dude what does yet
chin what's this one guys SpaceX hey
what is this
SpaceX successfully launched Falcon
Heavy
yesterday don't want that roadster
attached to it and a Guyana yeah base
outfit
spacesuit yeah so anyways these are the
Boosters that were on that rocket and
look how they land I still don't
understand how this is done
so this after that launched it up into
the air they split off and these are
falling back to the earth where do they
fall on their landing pad right there
let's listen to all the people chanting
like nerd you said that by [ __ ] nerds
it sounds like they're watching a super
polished um yeah this is all joke go go
these Rockets how do they how does this
possible that's science gin does it make
sense to you just looking at it though
no it looks like it's reversed the cab
can figure it out it looks like it's a
camera reverse camera no
no that's that's how they land which I'd
put the Jets on soft that's how they do
when they come back into orbit those
things that when they land the ocean
even those slow down they have the
shoots no these are actually landing
that way the first one that Rockets that
landed that way they didn't just
disintegrate or just go home no so they
come back to there and then they land
like this so they're guided I'm guided
yeah it's crazy
miss how high out no all right Spice
Girls are going on tour there's your
[ __ ] favorite band bro Mike in the
front row I suppose ain't poppin no more
I say that now you you insulted
everybody the Spice Girls ain't poppin
like they were when they were when they
were palpable that's fair
although Victoria isn't so you know like
the the Backstreet Boys and the rest of
the old a kill ants they kill a New Kids
on the Block not like it's not like you
hear it on the radio like you do but
that demographic the who are your guys
age now third you know me not to the
show the slights like that like you're
sliding both of us and then you're
trying to like skip forward I'm not
gonna have it all right sorry for using
that's that [ __ ] hat off grabbed you
by that [ __ ] over-over like stylized
hair and I will [ __ ] you up right right
say it again
dude you're riding a train no rap I
train what are you gonna do like that
yeah don't don't you honey that dude you
look like you're trying to make room but
you can't hide man don't grab the trophy
apologize up now he'll put it in your in
how am i any old Hall I won't make any
older jokes just like that right in your
dick hole
care of your ass for your ass Oh Wyatt
that old prostate I'm saying dude you're
not a Frederic Brennan will you throw
with him would win yeah this [ __ ] guy
that guy with him you be so [ __ ] up
yeah dude that's a charm so would you
wait we have a question would you submit
me or LexA me would you swing with a
submit or a punch I would never hit you
Reb ever so you do like a finger lock I
would just control you then then if you
wouldn't relax that bright jokey
unconscious damn yeah
I know yeah because you don't have a
defender Joe because you are a [ __ ]
basketball pansy you I'd [ __ ] you in the
ass but you scream I wouldn't scream
gasps don't--and I'd have you down and I
would like just when you when you come
to terms with enjoying it then daddy
nine how do you know I would exactly
like an it wouldn't take long you don't
know that the real you would come out be
like you be wearing Cologne there are a
lot of factors what do you got chin I'm
a Thurman crash yeah so uma Thurman
recently went off on Harvey Weinstein in
Queens you know for like neglect and
this in the on the set not Quinton oh
yeah and I don't want to talk about the
Harvey wants you think that's obvious I
want to say this about film sets TV sets
I've been on film sets
I work got punched in my face
accidentally I've had broken ribs I've
seen I saw Nic Cage when I did kiss of
death throw a stuntman the guy was
busted bleeding I had to go to the
hospital immediately
I've had friends get their nose broke as
a fight these things happen their
accents as actors you want to make it
real directors want the they want you to
try to do everything and just like
sometimes basketball coaches will take
things too far off football coach maybe
like get the [ __ ] out on the field
because I so no I'm saying that's not
something like you want to happen all
the time and I never had that with the
director
but these learning does happen it does
happen note that again
you got a preface it I'm not talking
about the Weinstein thing but uma
Thurman in kwinter to know and I'm not
sure I'm not gonna confirm it I think
they also had a romantic relationship he
wanted what he wanted she gave it
unfortunately there was a car accident
but have you heard the details his
Quentin goes well quit until she was so
scared to drive down it he goes so I
drove down at myself and it was a cat so
straight shot it's an accident Danny
goes would because the son would drive
the other way goes and when you go the
other way it does take an S turning that
was my fault but it was really just a
standard drives an accident that
happened on a set they HAP I mean it
happens last time people have died on
movie sets with accidents happen
randomly and and and you know I mean a
handful of times that's so funny hey did
that
just like I mean Tom Cruise does they
broke his ankle he didn't these Tom
Cruise to break his ankle on the new
visit of balsam and then he came back
and you're like ruptured his spleen or
some [ __ ] people break ribs
no but do you want to try when you're
doing big films yeah like when I choose
to do a big film yeah because a lot of
times when I try to turn them down hubby
yeah because you know what it is I'm not
I'm not going to be with the kids I'm
not mr. agent let me do it I'll do
anything I'll do anything different
egrant you know yeah I'll do anything
like you and for me it's like I I have a
look at the artistic merit of the
project okay so if you ever had a like a
thing on a set where you're like I don't
know something happened yeah I have like
cuz I had a thing I was doing Copland it
was [ __ ] cool were shooting on the
George Washington Bridge it was 3:00 in
the morning we had the bridge for two
hours Harvey Keitel smacked my [ __ ]
face oh [ __ ] I didn't complain now it's
happened just saying this Quentin
Tarantino was something the stuff happen
you know what though I was a measly the
video to rear up on a horse I was
supposed to rear up on a horse and my
buddy's a stuntman
that's what silent so good speed forward
cuz that's actually but that's if you
don't know I do not have drives going 35
miles another she's going 30 nobody was
on a dirt road in with the car that's a
turn hard and she got banged up yeah she
says that she says she has permanent
neck and holy geez I believe that and
then they saying they were covering up
our up I love him with Thurman I know
him with Herman I worked well that's no
joke does she's in her she was hurt but
but I'm just saying this doesn't have to
do this concussed
this being lumps together with the
Harvey Weinstein a sexual assaulting
which is unacceptable is a different
thing that what happens on TV and film
sets all the time all the time maybe
shouldn't even going that fast so that's
crazy
you see that you could have gotten hurt
you see what that's a sword and the
sword like hit her as soon as they
crashed she's gonna hook in the back of
the head you see it I know what you mean
hairy scary yeah that's that was that I
don't think it would the juice setup or
they're trying to kill no no conspiracy
no but usually a stunt man would not
allow you so I was supposed to rear up
on a horse my buddy goes what are you
gonna do I go I got a rear up on a horse
because you ever ridden I go yeah I've
written a lot have you I kind of have so
so he goes he goes I mean
I grew up riding though my mother made
me [ __ ] I don't wanna go into it but
I've written yes and so uh and so he
goes to me he goes he goes it was really
interesting is where do you have to do
this because you have to test the horse
first and I go is sixty miles out and
Kieran and he goes I'm coming with you
and I go you're not coming with me don't
worry buddy goes no let me just come for
the hell of it he comes so he goes and
he watches me ride and they make me do a
figure eight they made me trot around
maybe do a little cantering I'm like
okay I got it and it was so great you
guys all right you want to try to rear
up it's a stunt horse [ __ ] so so in all
you do is you you you sit low and you
pull the reins back and the horse will
rear saw was this Brokeback Mountain no
no this is for a sketch I was doing for
HBO or for okay get to the goddamn point
so I go so I go only [ __ ] so I go on the
point when the horse kicked you in the
phone oh no I'm about to rear up and and
my buddy goes he's not gonna he's not
gonna do it and I go what and he goes
you're not first of all you're not
riding that horse a horse is riding you
and the guy and he looks at the guy goes
am i right and the guy goes kinda you
know he goes honestly I mean you you can
rabbit that that horse is doing what you
can tell and he said your friend captain
save-a-ho I gotta make Bank here bro
then he goes like this he goes and then
Karen goes problem is he's he's gonna
that horses also roll trend right and
the guy goes yeah and he goes he's
pulling if he if you go up you're gonna
pull with your right hand cuz your right
handed I'm watching you're already
favoring your right hand that horse is
gonna roll you're not gonna know how to
jump off it's gonna roll on your body
and he looks a guy goes is that another
possibility the guy goes that is a
possibility he goes yeah we'll get a
horse guy you're not doing it that's why
you have summon cuz I didn't know that
I'd pushed it you know he's right
because I was I was what I didn't
realize is because I'm right handed the
horse kept going to the right cuz I'm
pulling more than right cuz I'm a little
nervous on the horse I've been written
on long time the horse rears up guess
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna pull up my
right that horse is gonna it's gonna
roll it's gonna do a trick and I'm not a
stuntman so I'm gonna have 1,200 pounds
on my body and it's awesome yeah I'm
just long enough for a Z do we have that
film and I'm like water and I would just
jump off but did you do you have the
clip of that yeah and you know what the
horse rolled on me I was fine and I
punched that horse is a bad face I'm
gonna say this right now I got to get
the [ __ ] out of here
alright this is so be up it one thirty
no just one hold on bro
what
you don't have anybody no I have nowhere
to go I have to go into the hem because
you gotta go with good park I had to
like park like 20 minutes away so I got
a walk to better go to Manhattan
Manhattan I thought you just said
Manhattan no [ __ ] I said I said
I got to go man [ __ ] I know I'm gonna be
silly play hoops at the Rec Center or
the rest of white boys yeah in the
valley or shake what you got to do huh
right to the [ __ ] doctor code you get
that World War Z cough going on oh I can
tuberculosis bro and I don't like you
coming up mash down those quarters ya
mad cowlings replace this for the next
guest you know [ __ ] all right
can I go yeah I guess so go ahead Brad
go get quarantined right now I'm College
Center for Disease Control right now
well we can't end this podcast without
getting your input on this weekend's
pay-per-view you'll see to 21 it's in
Australia it's in Perth Australia shout
out to all my Australians yeah yo Romero
your dot your boy your boyfriend Ivan
tell your safe-side a1 must be loved and
my boyfriend for sidepiece Luke Ross
yeah the promise first of all before you
dive in yeah who has a better body you
know okay here's what I'm gonna say
about that say about that it for my
local Jules
yeah for for just for just pure off
factor it's gotta be you al Romero right
he looks like a from Factor genic
genetic factor yeah yeah he's a cartoon
character
correct but they don't one's an actual
model right then you have say to me with
money what are women drawn to more I'm
gonna go with Luke Rockhold they tend to
like less muscle-bound longer leaner
kind of that Calvin Klein look so you
gotta go so it just depends it's just
you're going with Luke
cuz he makes money off his body yeah all
right that's fair I like your question
though now the real question who wins
this fight this weekend that's five
rounds now keep in mind that you're out
with the exception of the Tim Kennedy
fight which he ended up winning but if
you actually look at how he gassed and
Tim one sort of and then it was the Bell
dual controversy so so this dual
controversy dual gauge
believe that's the only time that I've
ever seen you l lose and I believe what
about chuckle a decision decision and it
was a very very close fight so I didn't
see anybody beat anybody in that right
but I got it along the way no Rob right
so I got no problem with it so what I'm
really saying is I've actually never
seen you out actually get B um
assume you're tired see him get tired
they're seeing Luka thing No
so here's that here's the issue here's
the issue and this is why I'm going with
Luke Rockhold me too
I got to go with Luke because Luke first
of all I think his striking is every bit
as good as you Elle's or better better I
think Luke is an outstanding mm a
wrestler because remember who his
training partners were forever a guy
named still Alaska's Angela and mr. mr.
Daniel Cormier now Yoel is a world
champion I've always said I want to do
I've always said the fight that was my
excitement more than anything is you
well Daniel Cormier I don't know why you
wants to call Daniel out too small yells
too small his wrestling would beg to
differ on that though I would imagine
anyway I don't think so having said that
having said that I'm giving it to Luke
because I think Luke and I think you
well we'll try to keep it on the feet I
think Luke has the edge there and I
think ul is is by the nature of the
muscle he has to feed eventually going
to gas I think Luke's better on the
ground way better
that's fair as far as grappling goes
yeah Luke's a monster a monster on a
grabbed black belt yeah high level yeah
although you have to call it ran I just
say it's anything about that when you're
well fought
shocker a who's as good as it gets on
the ground he just stood up when he
wanted to stand up like you're not
holding you well down your well just
stay I'm saying even if loose on his
back yeah Luke on his back trouble for
you as well and remember Luke what went
the distance with chakra as well and
beat him yes he did okay my only problem
with my only problem with Luke is how
bad does I still want it ring rust and
his his last fight was against David
branch he did not look great he had
finally caught his
wind and did work in sated branch but
it's taking so much time off he's
talking about you can make more money
modeling so that's a little scary but I
think Luke gets it done I don't know how
do you know it change how long he gets
it done well how do you think he gets it
done round round and how does he well I
think this fight I actually think this
fight goes the distance who I don't and
I think that ul gets so tired by the
body by the fifth round you just you see
Luke take over as soon as you all gets
tired I think Luke finished ism with a
head kick or a body kick and TKO ISM
I'll say third or fourth round really
Luke Rockhold Wow
and then a fight would occur and then
he'll go to 205 Wow
then what about the coming of a markup
verse curtis blades I mean you know I'd
go Mark Hunt I have to go with Mark
hunches area just by sheer experience
and power and all the team Curtis blades
via decision yeah I hate to do that cuz
I love markup but whatever all right Ben
there you go live C 221 3 embraer about
but you'll be able to see it illegally
streaming in the back like you always do
Bob and Brea I will be in brown water
you Billy I gotta be that far we know
you go figure it out no no don't do that
not a hey hey you'll figure it out no no
I don't know about that Dana no hold on
hold on you know you'll figure out the
same way Bieber did no no no don't you
see fever
use on the roads like I can't watch you
if sees anyone have a link I can watch
on and Dan responds back goes hey you
cheap [ __ ] don't you buy it like
everybody I'd like everybody else now
you'll see it I can't wait to see it's
on pay-per-view mm-hmm I won't look at
my phone I'll record it tell me we're
gonna be out this weekend be Brea Bryant
I'm at brand prov Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday Thursday Friday Saturday
hands-on that's a lot of weekend it's a
lot of tickets
come on out kids let's go see Brian the
kid Kalin and that following week come
see me at the Tempe improv on
Valentine's Day Wednesday and then
Thursday Friday Saturday I'm at Phoenix
live in Phoenix boom
I am in La Jolla the Comedy Store at La
Jolla San Diego and I am there actually
Friday and Saturday I'm not there son
it's just Friday Saturday for shows too
Friday - on Saturday - gets T fat K calm
and also some of our shows my life by we
love it there and I love it that I've
been there before also Florida I'm in
Tampa which there's 10 tickets left to
Tampa sells out Palm Beach Friday and
Saturday and then Sunday Orlando in
Orlando is also almost sold out so you
get tickets right now P fat K calm also
as you're listening this 5:00 p.m.
Pacific we're rerelease in the original
Abbot Kinney Fight Club
hoodies so those are back in stock get
them right now to fake a calm this is
the fire the kid with Rappaport we're
out